I ordered clear digest and protein
enzyme for you and wondering if this will help my system,
as I am having terrible bloating and gas with skateboards.
Yes, I would try the, the digest, the clear digest.
That's what I recommended when Megan asked me about
what would be the best thing for you.
And remember, with your digestive enzymes,
you want to titrate them if you're having issues
like bloating and stuff.
The titrating means I'm going to take one with a meal.
Well, I didn't really help them still getting bloating.
And then tomorrow I'm going to take two with a meal.
Then you can go about three, four days.
I'm trying to titrate up slowly and titrate down.
You get to a point where you might have to take like six
or seven per meal until finally, wow, this is really helping.
Then you start to titrate down.
You don't have to be on that kind of dose forever
by any stretch of the imagination that you might have to
titrate up to really get your body working.
Then you titrate back down in a kiln.